hey everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today we are doing
a reaction tonight citywire episode 3
this video is sponsored by scavengers
which basically just means they'll be
one of my ads in the middle of it rather
than one of youtube's ads
all throughout so i have already watched
this but because i was doing live
production because i was hosting the
twitch stream it kind of means you miss
a lot of information because you're
trying to organize what the post show is
going to look like
um so now is technically my second watch
through but i'm going to be able to pay
a lot more attention and kind of digest
more details which i'm very excited
about
also so let's do it
i love this song that they keep using
every day
it's a good intro it's tasty okay hello
and
welcome hello holly city wire episode
iii the show from us
at cd projekt red where we talk about
all things
cyberpunk 2077 in today's episode
we're going to start by taking you on a
tour of night city
in a new gameplay video for the record
and have a chat with seniors night city
fully does
like my playing experience is everything
that they're showing you
it's not fake it really does make a
gameplay video and have a chat with mata
from um for anyone who doesn't know
finish today's episode
we're going to get four hours of the
game incredible
fine lists in my audience makes fun of
me for how often i bring that up
but i do it in case this is the first
players have been of my cyberpunk videos
that you have seen so let's get started
it's time to take you on a tour of night
city
wonderful
yesterday that i am in the game but uh i
love this game regardless i want to
inject all of the information into my
veins
today's news is nova max
it's not so bad here but it looks like
today
because i feel amazing
the food the tie on seventh and hayward
the pierogies down by the docks i did
like while i was playing occasionally
see repeated npc types
and as always your business is my
business which is something that's
standard for video games obviously
but i feel like people may have
expectations where npcs are concerned
that they maybe shouldn't have
in some cases all this um
the tv broadcast stuff you see um is
often shown in like elevators or on
billboards i think
as well i definitely saw live talk shows
while i was in elevators
possibilities so much personality
we are [ __ ] america and i don't know
how we're gonna fix it
the homeless population in night city
has risen by three hundred percent
they're like individually drew united
states
that's a fight this city won't let you
win
on your own you're [ __ ] thanks kiane
[Music]
yeah well on that note that's it for
today's info flash
sleep tight night city the grass ain't
greener anywhere else
night city that's badly what does it
mean to you how well do you know it's
history
we're definitely seeing some of the
districts hit too like many stations you
can just visually see how different they
are which city district boasts the
best burrito in town the answers to
these questions and more
can be found at the address at the
bottom of your scene it's a real website
by the way i went to it
i look so blue my white balance is
having trouble with
the fact that i'm wearing makeup today
[Music]
i'm assuming that that song is an
original for the game
it's really nice i like it a lot
super excited about the soundtrack
that's the one well since night city is
one of our stars of this episode
there is actually quite a lot to talk
about so let's start at the beginning
how did night city come to be because
yes it exists in the world of the
tabletop
but uh how do you take that and make
what we've got now
well yeah as you can imagine making a
city that is as big
and complex as night city is is
quite the ambitious description first
off we sat down and we were really
concerned pretty big what is it that we
wanted to do with night city
in a way night city is this style of
cyberpunk right it is one of its
main characters we wanted to make a city
that is very very believable right i
loved uh
immersion gets thrown around a lot but
really when i played you to be able to
dive into different people's like styles
and fashion senses
and then secondly we also wanted to
provide enough variety between districts
so that exploring night city would
always be fun right there's no point
in making a city that is all all city
and you know it doesn't really matter
where you go because once you've been
through one district you feel like
you've been through all of them so for
that
we first of started taking a look at the
real life geography that night city is
located on and that would be
on the coast of california knowing that
night city would be
a coastal city gave us a bit of insight
into what we would
expect from the city layout you'd expect
the port
you'd expect huge industrial areas that
would facilitate this kind of
la vibes i feel like that's consistent a
kind a city of this type
would have with the world and then we
went through
and actually divided the city into
several districts
six of them and some of them are based
on the original
lore we decided to give their own
characteristics in terms of
architecture their demographics and
similar soccer [ __ ] right there
and also the function within the city
each of these districts in turn we
divide it into further sub-districts
which we further characterized using the
more grand
theme of the larger district this
process
i think has resulted in a city that is
feels quite alive has a lot of
jackie's dancing i didn't catch that
last time it feels like it's only
because they interject
without feeling separated from the
larger picture
and that results in something that
allows the player to easily navigate
even the complex concrete jungles of
night city
simply by looking around and always
having a rough idea
where you actually are but my city is
clearly so
different from anything we've ever
created with the witcher can you give us
some idea about
or some insight into just how big and
like how densely packed
night city really is it's a good
question yes um thank you
i'm not exaggerating when i'm saying
that night city is easily the most
complex thing
that i or the others have worked on the
city
super organic right it's not like a
chessboard layout
but the the layout of the city is crazy
and you can tell that it
grew in phases right where buildings
have been built on top of each other
and i guess the mega buildings that we
have showcased are a great example of
this
um you'll actually see that they are
located
some kind of pillar you know and then
expand outside and then
up up high into the sky and underneath
these complex felt like a city in itself
buildings this yields a lot of
interesting experiences when it comes to
exploration very dramatic it's the one
thing i'm most excited about the players
to experience
we've been saying that our exploration
is super vertical
right but what this really means is that
it changes the way you
explore the city compared to our
previous games
you won't be able to easily set out on a
target in the distance right you won't
be able to say oh there's a castle on a
hill over there i'll try to get there
and then you'll be lost on the way
but here it's much more intimate much
more moment to moment you might be
roaming the cities
and get a call by your fixer who informs
you about a job nearby that you might be
able to do right
or you find an alleyway and you walk
down one of the many many alleyways that
the city has to offer and it's
always a surprise you don't know you
might stumble upon some gangers hanging
out that are up to no good
sometimes and these are the ones that i
often get surprised with you even
stumble upon
the odd elevator that is meant to
connect parts of the
i thought they were loading screens dev
told me today that they aren't and it's
quite astonishing
elevators aren't loading screens i don't
know
and now i'm here now i know that
elevators literally are to just move you
between things it's crazy again
this all serves to really enhance this
sense of wonder that we all come to love
from open world games and the whole city
is built to cater to that
i mean you guys have really brought
night city to life and i really want to
make a point of that it is a living
breathing city
so as a level designer can you give us
some insight into those little touches
that you guys have made because
i hear you guys even been placing
rubbish by hand
oh yes um we've been placing quite a bit
of rubbish and that's certainly one of
the more glorious parts of being a level
designer or an environment artist where
you get to litter
the streets that you've spent time
building with the garbage but it's
details such as this that um crazy
that's somebody's job important
to make the city feel alive and also we
take great pride
in the process of making this right we
have a lot of fun actually
placing a lot of what we call mini
stories right
these are little encounters um that when
i play
when you simply walk along i explored a
lot
of the indoor environments right sides
we have
just kinda stop down for a minute and
take a look at your surroundings
and that we have so lovingly created and
try to see if there maybe isn't
something that you can be a little
detective for
now one other thing that i think is
really really cool is also the fact that
we have
um actually named every single street in
the city
so not only will npcs be able to
communicate their
locations or the locations they want you
to visit by sort of referring to the
street names
but also you will be able to talk to
your friends about it in that way right
have you been to poplar street in japan
town for example
um and i think this is a small detail
but the philosophy
that we have with these kind of things
it's called you know many many small
things
that contribute to the sum of it which
is hopefully then you being able to
explore
a city that you feel is truly alive and
that you haven't
been experiencing before it's time to
interrupt this broadcast with a
scheduled advertisement
seriously i'm here to tell you guys
about a game you might not know about
called scavengers developed by midwinter
entertainment who are a game development
studio established by veterans of halo
battlefield
gears of war among many others actually
josh holmes co-founded the studio
uh who you might know as a past studio
head of 343 industries
or the dude that i interviewed on this
channel like seven years ago because i'm
sure you all watched that video
so scavenges is a strategic survival
battleground you can enter a
free-to-play action shooter where squads
of three compete to survive and dominate
in a hybrid of sandbox style pve and
class-based pvp
there are a bunch of different explorers
a bunch of different unique abilities
and weapons
and an opportunity for you to conquer
the challenges of a hostile wasteland
i am here to tell you that the game does
have a technical play test this weekend
from september 18 to 20. i'll leave a
link in the description to where you can
sign up to check out the playtest uh
there's no catch that's all you have to
do
just check it out if you're interested
in the game which for the record takes
place
in the far future after a cataclysmic
asteroid strike
has shattered the moon and plunged earth
into a second ice age
an alien virus contained within the
asteroid has corrupted life on the
planet giving rise to savage and twisted
creatures including former humans
it's pretty messed up and yeah the game
will be coming to pc in 2021 and to ps4
and xbox one
at a later date i will say that um sorry
to talk over you holly
is your insight i suppose when the game
launches you could be
no i'm just distracted by her anyway
though right it might be
yeah you know if this game death thing
doesn't work out for me uh
there were like hallways that just sort
of ended for no reason like one of them
literally just went to black when i
played but for the most part
um anything again even areas of
locations that you wouldn't go to had
loads of detail from the sixth street to
the valentinos
it's time to introduce you to the gangs
of night city
[Music]
you know how things work damn
stronger survive but that's how things
stand
you're either somebody where you fizzle
out into nothing
that lets you get by with our buddies be
very careful my friend
we are all so far from home
which gang's the city's biggest and
baddest according to the ncp and let's
scare them
title more maelstrom depending on the
season
one time a maelstrom ganger killed a
young kid right in front of my eyes
for shits and giggles sucking psychos
and who the [ __ ] are you to say what can
and can't be i just gotta
do that to our meat grinder
about time we had some fun big mouths
you'll never forget
never they got little clubs for their
own gang that's cute she's a gang like
any other right
i'll take the valentinos they follow god
and the santa madre honor means
something to him how'd you meet jackie
we started out together the valentinos
no
in the [ __ ] bible book club i gotta
give style points to the valentinos
they have a punishment for every
occasion i met him
quick shout out to everyone domingo
lately the valentino's in sixth street
have had a bigger bone to pick
sixth street why'd they want to wipe you
i don't know can't [ __ ] stick
to the elections basically yeah i did
that exactly direct street before
we do the run they'll transfer the cred
come on let's go before sixth street
shows up
shut up shut up any more second
amendment fans of the house
hate those bastards vomit lofty
patriotic [ __ ] all day
time to bring on the future nice keanu
nice any idea how many attacks from
boys are very cool neutralized if the
voodoo boys breach the black wall we'll
all be [ __ ]
voodoo boys urban myth i thought
just net runners spooking each other no
such gang you know i heard a few things
about you the voodoo boys
best runners in town you do not steal
from the voodoo boys
i see you always oh he's so cool
pacifica is just haiti
i love that stuff your own island cut
off from the rest of the city
this is our turf our home until last
week
the animals crawled in animals are the
craziest
[ __ ] gang terrified
that song i love that what is it
somewhere at the start of the story
somebody [ __ ] the corp
see how this works now meredith stout
you can romance her husband's new
westbrook okay i know almost nothing
about the tiger class
they did what made the best eddies sword
sex and black market
see a lot of tigers they know what else
they do well
break the needs of people who ask
questions we gotta do something shut the
[ __ ] up the tigers will kill us
sort of like y'all come on baby
claws killed super interesting many so
people took matters into their own hands
the devastating day was saying that they
like militarized sex workers it was like
girls
i'm into it the whole freak show it's
how the mocs got started
us half each other's back we look out
for one
another you're looking for some company
tonight how did you hook up with the
mocks
i thought susie judy you could really
change i like her
i think i'm gonna romance her boxes and
nomads don't seem so different
bro seem to yammer a lot about community
solidarity
tell me about the badlands not much
going on out here
oh contraire this is an ecosystem
nomads raptor shiv corporations and
drifters
they form a complete hole remove one
part
the delicate balance topples here in the
aldocaldos it all stays in the family
classic dilemma what comes from i really
feel like we know nothing about what's
outside the city walls super curious
this family will go to hell and back
everyone in this i guess i like it i
like that i only know i know the first
five hours of the game i would say
quite well quicksand i know pretty much
exactly what happens
um still have so many questions love
that about it thank you they did say
the main quest is shorter than it was
excited because apparently people
complain
we've shown a little bit on twitter but
their styles are so distinct
yes i enjoyed them a lot as well in our
game i think they're very cool but let's
start them with the kind of role that
they play because gangs really do play a
prominent role in night city correct
yes definitely the gangs they they're
also confirmed today
you know they have the newest cyberware
they have the newest weaponry
and they are really a power that
everyone needs to take into account when
they are
thinking of operating in night city you
will encounter interesting things
but also versus militech in our song
quest side quest
different jobs for the for the fixers uh
sometimes you might even get hired by
them
but then i suppose everybody's thinking
then can you
join again well there is a merc
and mercs of night city are this unique
distinct group
that stick mostly to themselves right
and they get jobs from
variety of factions they can get jobs
from corporations they can get jobs from
gangs they can get job from
different kind of like influential
clients because of this
nobody will ever trust a merc to be one
of them
right and the gangs are no exception
here they are looking only for like
people that they know will be loyal to
them right and that they will fight for
their cause
all of the time not just some of the
times when it's profitable to them so
because of this we will mostly stick to
the afterlife and the after
our life are this group of mercs this
legendary group of mercy yeah so
after life is like a club not a job the
best clients and so on so if you want to
become a legend
in night city you are going to the
afterlife
so we've obviously mentioned distinct
style then so does that mean there are
kind of special gang themed weapons and
items and clothing for players to find
and
use yes definitely there are different
vehicles that you can drive for example
there are cars there are motorbikes
um it sounds like there are all quarters
there are different pieces of clothing
yeah i'm team
i think it's cool there are weapons and
so on so
yeah definitely there are things to look
forward to didn't get to try a guitar i
suppose as somebody who's spent as much
time as you have
kind of getting to know the gangs i have
to ask which is your favorite and why
so i would have to say probably
maelstrom
uh simply because they have a crazy
unique distinct feel uh and this
weird aesthetic about them creepy so the
idea
is they are people who want to cross the
boundary between
the machine and human right they are
changing so much of their body with
cyberware that they
no longer look human really on top of
that they are also very unpredictable
uh it's very difficult to say what they
will do
at any point when you meet them uh at
one moment they can be shaking hands
with you and at the other moment
you know they will pull gun gun out on
you and they bring in this element of
chaos into the game which i
really enjoy personally oh matty thank
you
so much for joining us it was
interesting to learn
what uh your favorite gang is i think it
kind of tells me a little bit about you
oh does it what does it say about me
well we'll talk about that later but for
now
before we wrap up today's episode we
asked people
to show us their creation this stuff is
really cool i didn't know they were
doing this today i can't believe how
every time i see it i'm so blue
my webcam is so off judges selected it's
very small caught on my lip that it's
made look
enormous national case models oh well
bring their concept
this is very cool reality i didn't know
they were doing this and then they're
auctioning one off for charity i suppose
these five amazing designs will be
fighting for the main prize
an alienware aurora pc along with other
awesome gaming peripherals
brought to you by our partners alienware
nvidia
and steelseries let's see the mods
it's so rad i absolutely
love this one you kidding
aesthetic works with each other
absolutely next level honestly kind of
terrifying
that's so nuts
exactly so cool the creativity i would
expect to find out a trade show
it really looks like it could have come
straight out of the game
bonkers man
it's like i'm sort of scared of it like
oh very cool
to watch the full pc case modding video
and to get more information about when
the winning design will be available on
charity auction stay tuned to our
schools
i respect it looking at those pc case
mods it reminds me that we do have
one more thing to reveal the space if
you're going to be playing cyberpunk
2077 on pc when it launches this
november
we do have some specs to share that i
think some of you have been waiting for
the minimum system requirements for
cyberpunk are a windows 7
or 10 pc an intel core i5
i definitely remember this and like
spoke about this at length but
ultimately fx 8310
minimum requirements are lower than i
expected nvidia geforce
gtx 780 or an amd and radio
x470 is about to say it in the storage
department the game will take up roughly
70 gigs of space
way smaller than that we'll rub off a
hdd we do recommend
an ssd as for the rest it's just i don't
know how this game runs
i don't understand knight city's huge i7
dev told me today elevators aren't
loading screens which is how a lot of
people
hide loading you know dead space effect
i don't know how this game functions
but it's so big and there's so many
moving parts
radiant r9 fury it's
don't forget that if you've missed
anything or if you just want to watch
again we will be uploading everything to
our channels
shortly and we will be back soon with
episode four
wonderful i guess it's probably one more
episode before the game comes out
november 19th
i think that's it it looks like there's
a little bit left on the video but i'm
pretty sure it's
there's nothing actually left yeah um
another really good one
super into it uh super excited the only
thing that i'm still really really not
sold on including the little bit of
um gameplay that we saw there with the
fight against the
animal who still mostly was terrifying
is merely combat
i still i didn't get to try it i
stupidly didn't try it um
so i can't speak to it myself but i i
don't it doesn't look great to me
uh so that's the only thing that i'm not
like 100 sure about like including
what we saw today but everything else
happy with it
super [ __ ] excited that's my genuine
opinion
i am also in the game and do have to
tell you that uh but you know it is
also like literally beside that [ __ ]
excited regardless
uh glad to hear that we get another one
of these too you're like
i will take this content forever until
the game comes out
um alrighty guys thank you so much for
watching i will see you all next time
bye